تعاني المنطقه الشرقيه من نقص النحاد في
المشاريع السياحيه البحريه رغم امتلاكها
لشواطئ رمليه هي الاطول على سواحل الخليج
العربي
وسطات تساؤلات عن غياب المستثمرين عن
الاستثمار في المشاريع السياحيه البحريه
في المنطقه من جهه اخرى اعلنت امانه
المنطقه الشرقيه عن توقيع عقد استثماري
لمشروع تطوير منتجع بشاطئ نصف القمر اوضحت
الامانه ان المشروع يشتمل على مركز او على
تطوير مراكزه للترفيه والسياحه ومجموعه من
الخدمات المسانده كالمقاهي والمطاعم وصحه
عامه واطلالات مفتوحه متعدده الاستخدامات
من الخبر ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصي اهلا عبد الرحمن ما هي حقيقه
الشواطئ في المنطقه الشرقيه من حيث
المشاريع السياحيه البحريه
نعم خالد مع بدايه اقتراب موسم الصيف في
كل عام يتساءل الكثير من سكان المنطقه
الشرقيه لماذا هذه المنطقه تفتقر الى
المشاريع السياحيه البحريه النوعيه لا
سيما بان منطقه الشرقيه تضم اطول سواحل
بحريه على ضفاف الخليج العربي الى جانب
طبعا هناك الكثير من الرمال الشاطئيه في
غايه الجمال والروعه بدايه من نشاط العقير
في الجنوب وصولا الى مدينه الخفجي الحدود
الكويتيه السعوديه لكن هذه المشاريع لا
تزال يعني بطيئه الى حد ما بحسب اراء
المواطنين هنا في المنطقه الشرقيه ولعل
اخر المشاريع التي يعني اثارت الاسئله حول
هذا الموضوع هو تطوير شاطئ نصف القمر
واعطاء هناك موقع لاحد المستثمرين الحديث
اكثر عن هذه الزوايا خارج الضم الي
المهندس عبد الله البقومي وهو مدير
المشاريع في
المدن الشؤون المشاريع والاداريه في
الفنيه والاداريه في اماكن الشرقيه مهندس
عبد الله نتكلم عن مشروع عنه مؤخرا في
شاطئ نصف القمر نتكلم عن تفاصيل ارقام حول
هذا المشروع
ومتوقع متى الانتهاء منه حياكم الله جميعا
متابعين ومستمعين ومشاهدين
في البدايه ولله الحمد تم توقيع مجموعه من
العقود الاستثماريه كما ذكرت في شاطئ نصف
القمر بمساحه تتجاوز الثلاثه مليون متر
مربع هي مشاريع سياحيه رياضيه ترفيهيه
تجاريه كما ذكرت لكم تجاوز مساحتها ثلاثه
مليون متر مربع يوجد فيها منتجعات سياحيه
بالاضافه الى الان في احد المواقع في
مدينه الخبر تم
تاجيره على احد المستثمرين بالضبط
كما ذكرت لكم منتجعات سياحيه بالاضافه الى
منطقه لحلبه السيارات ايضا من المشاريع
التي نفخر فيها في امانه المنطقه الشرقيه
هو مشروع الشاطئ المعياري اللي تتجاوز
مساحته اكثر من 100 الف متر مربع وهو
الشاطئ الاول من نوعه على توقع ينتهي من
المشروع هذا مش لازم نتطرق لها هو مشروع
تطوير الواجهه البحريه الموجود في كورنيش
الخبر هو المشروع الاول من نوعه بالتعاون
مع مركز التخصيص حيث يوجد فيه
سنوي محدد بالاضافه الى نسبه مهندس
عبدالله تتفق مع وجهه النظر اللي تقول انه
فعلا منطقه شرقيه تفتقر الى المشاريع
السياحيه البحريه
خاصه مقارنه بالدول القريبه مثل البحرين
الامارات قطر نرى نرى في امانه المنطقه
الشرقيه ان المشاريع ونوعيه المشاريع في
المنطقه الشرقيه واعره ولله الحمد يوجد
اكثر من مشروع موجود على منصه فرص الان
على سبيل الذكر للحصر مشروع المدينه
الترفيهيه اللي موجود في نصف شاطئ نصف
القمر بمساحه تتجاوز الميه الف متر مربع
ايضا من المشاريع التي لازم
التي لازم نتطرق لها هو مشروع النقل
البحري الذي يربط عديد من المحافظات
الموجوده في المنطقه الشرقيه شمالا من
الجبيل وصولا الى شاطئ العقير هذا المشروع
طرح في منصه استثمر في السعوديه بالتعاون
مع وزاره الاستثمار ووزاره الشؤون البلديه
والقرويه وهيئه تطوير المنطقه وهيئه
الهيئه الملكيه في الجبيل وينبع بالاضافه
الى امانه الاحساء مرورا بعدد من
المحافظات منها راس تنوره والدمام والخبر
والكفجي هذا المشروع الان موجود على منصه
فرص ومنصه استثمر في السعوديه
شكرا جزيلا خالد يعني كما سمعنا هنا
مؤخرا ضيفك العزيز
والسؤال يعني اليوم
هل من المعقول انه توه مثلا
المستثمرين او التفتوا لاهميه هذه المنطقه
اهميتها هذه السواحل افتقادها الى
المشاريع يعني مش اللي كان يمنعهم من
الاقبال على الاستثمار في سواحل طويله في
منطقه مهمه زي المنطقه
الشرقيه وهي مربحه مش كان الاسباب اللي
تمنعها وش اللي اختلف اليوم
نعم زميلي خالد يسال لماذا المستثمرين
كانوا مبتعدين عن مثل هذه المشاريع
السياحيه في المنطقه الشرقيه وش اللي تغير
وخلاهم يقبلون الفتره القليله الماضيه
اعتقد وجود عديد من المحفزات التي قامت
فيها وزاره الشؤون البلديه والقرويه فعلى
سبيل الذكر للحصر يوجد نسبه اعفات 10% من
مده العقد فهذه احد الامتيازات التي قامت
فيها وزاره الشؤون البلديه والقرويه في
الامانه رصدت مؤخرا اقبال كبير من
المستثمرين تغير الوضع شوي فعلا
الاستثمارات الاستثمارات في القطاع البلدي
تطورت مؤخرا فعلى سبيل اللي ذكرته لكم
عشره في المئه نسبه اعفاء على سبيل المثال
لو عقدك 25 سنه فانت تتكلم عن سنتين ونص
ما راح يكون فيه اي قيمه مقابل التاجير
بالاضافه الى الامور التي تحسنت التاجير
في القطاع البلدي او الاستثمار في القطاع
البلدي هي تقليص نسبه الضمان البنكي سابقا
كانت 100%
والزملاء نتطلع الى الفرص الاستثماريه
بتحليل فني سابقا ننظر الى العرض المالي
فقط الان ننظر نحلل المشاريع تحليل فني
فالمشروع الذي يحصل على اعلى نتيجه في
عمليه التحليل الفني هو الذي يحصل على
الموقع في السابق كان الموضوع مختلف شكرا
اعتقد خالد يعني ربما الفتره المقبله نشهد
العديد من التطور والحراك في المنطقه
الشرقيه فيما يتعلق بالمشاريع السياحيه
البحريه
شكرا
لك يعطيك العافيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي
مراسل العربيه من شاطئ في مدينه الخبر